(drum music)
- Philip, stop.
We're not supposed to be
doing that after 6:00 PM.
- Who says?
- Our HOA?
It says so clearly in the CC&Rs
- The Credence Clearwater Revival?
- Covenants, conditions and restrictions.
- Give me a break.
This is America.
Nobody can tell an adult what
they can do in their own home.
- Actually, they can.
(upbeat music)
There are so many important
factors to consider when
buying a house from mortgage terms
to inspections to school districts.
It's understandable
that some things that don't
seem too important now
will get neglected only
to bite you down the road.
- One such example is the HOA
or Homeowners Association.
A self-governing board
that oversees a community
of homeowners, whether
in single family homes,
townhouses, or condos.
HOAs are funded by monthly dues collected
from all members and exist
to keep property values high.
The main ways they do this are
by offering amenities and
enforcing restrictions.
- Amenities offered by HOAs
come in many different flavors.
A gated community might have
security guards patrolling
at night.
A subdivision of tract houses might have
a community swimming pool
and a condominium building needs to keep
the elevators working and
the lobby neat and tidy.
- These things all cost
money and the amount of dues
collected will reflect the
extravagance of the amenities.
A simple HOA that offers
a garbage pickup service
and maintains a playground
might only ask residents
for $150 a month while a
beachfront condo could easily
charge $1,000 a month to operate a spa
and fitness center.
- You can't opt out of
paying for these amenities.
So before you commit,
make an honest assessment
of whether you'll actually use them.
Generally, the services that
make everyday life easier
like snow shoveling or garbage pickup
are a safer bet than luxuries
like gyms and swimming pools.
- But restrictions are where
HOAs really flex their muscles.
Do you live for Halloween
and literally count the
days until you can bedeck
your house with all manner
of ghosts and ghoulies?
Better read those CC&Rs pretty closely
because some HOAs may
prohibit holiday decorations
of any kind, let alone the
gory tableau you've dreamed up.
- Maybe your family has three cars,
but only a two car garage.
That's okay, you can
just park the extra one
on the street, right?
Well, that depends.
No HOA has jurisdiction
over public streets.
But if the street is private,
like say in a gated community,
HOA can make rules about
what kinds of vehicles
can park there, for how long
or even prohibit street parking entirely.
They can even dictate
whether you can park your
car in your own driveway.
- Let's say you've just
inherited the handmade farmhouse
mailbox your grandfather made.
Better rethink it as a backyard birdhouse
because your new HOA loves
uniformity above all else.
Some even require your roof shingles
to match your neighbors.
- Other common restrictions
include no parties,
no renters, no flags,
no long-term visitors,
no pets over 25 pounds or no pets period.
- Okay, but are these
really ironclad rules
or just guidelines?
If you bent them a little bit,
how much trouble could
you really get into?
- The answer, a lot.
- Courts in many states have determined
that CC&Rs are legally binding documents
unless they violate public policies.
Depending on the terms,
you could be fined, sued
or have a lien put on your home.
HOAs don't play. One
in Florida confiscated
80 residents' trash bins
and dropped them off
at a recycling center for
leaving them in plain view
for too long. A man in
California had to pay $70,000
of his HOAs legal expenses
and lost his home.
His crime?
Planting too many rose
bushes in his front yard.
- So if you think you'll
have trouble complying
with any of your HOA's restrictions
it's best to look elsewhere
rather than risk a showdown.
Conversely, these restrictions might just
be what you're looking for, like say,
if you're deathly afraid of
dogs or have trouble sleeping
and don't want to be
disturbed by loud neighbors.
- Once you've balanced the amenities
with the restrictions and
dues, there's one more aspect
of your HOA to consider, assessments.
- Sometimes major repairs
are required on shared spaces
like if the community
pool needs resurfacing
or the elevators need special maintenance
or the roof of a condo
is damaged in a storm.
In these cases, the HOA may
have the authority to demand
that every member chip in to
pay for the emergency upkeep
which depending on the
problem, and the number
of members can result
in an unexpected levy
in the hundreds or even
thousands of dollars.
- These surprise fees
are known as assessments
and though they can feel onerous
they are not to be taken lightly.
Take for example, the collapse
of the Champlain Towers
South condo building
in Miami in June of 2021.
For years before the
tragedy, the condo board knew
that the building was
in dire need of repair
but was reluctant to ask the residents
for the 80 to $200,000 in assessments
it would cost per unit.
- Part of the problem is that
HOA boards are often made up
of volunteer members who have
little experience in finance
or construction and are
under pressure from residents
to keep dues as low as possible.
According to one study, about
one third of such associations
have less than a third of
the savings they'd need
to pay for sudden, but eventual repairs.
- As Jeffrey Ducker, a principal
in the audit department
of a Florida public
accounting firm, put it,
if you're looking to buy a
home in an HOA, be sure to ask
for a copy of its financial statements.
Look at what its liquidity is,
if it has sufficient
working capital to operate
and if it has set aside reserves
for future major repairs
and replacement. If it
doesn't have reserves
that would be considered
a negative factor.
- Despite the cost and the pitfalls,
HOAs are actually pretty popular.
The Community Associations
Institute reports that 85%
of residents that have an
HOA are satisfied with it.
Additionally, researchers at
the University of California
at Irvine found that homes with an HOA
sold for 4% more than
those without on average.
For many people,
HOAs can make their home
a better place to live
and a safer investment.
As long as you have a competent board
and can abide by the restrictions,
you might be one of them.
- So I can go back to
practicing the drums?
- Only between the hours of 10 and six
or you could get an electric
kit and put on some headphones
which actually sounds
like a good idea to me.
- [Group] And that's our two cents.
- Thanks to our patrons
for keeping "Two Cents"
financially healthy.
Click the link
in the description to
become a "Two Cents" patron.
(upbeat music)
- For more about the unexpected bumps
on the path to home ownership,
check out our video,
"How Do You Actually Buy a House?
(upbeat music)